[Musique]
christian jacob et donc notre invité ce
midi dont bfm politique président des
républicains sommes au coeur de
l'actualité depuis hier soir notamment
une de la presse ce matin hier vous avez
donc annoncé le mode désignation choisi
par par vos adhérents pour le candidat à
la présidentielle qui va vous
représentez ce sera donc un congrès
c'était votre choix personnel vous êtes
satisfait mais moi je suis satisfait que
la décision était été prise j'avais
toujours dit depuis le début que même
légitimité je la tiens des militants
c'est aux militants qu'il revenait de
décider du mode de désignation
d'ailleurs c'est aussi statutaire ça
vous ne pouvez pas modifier les statuts
sans passer par un pra congrès donc
cette décision est prise elle est bien
prise dans un débat démocratique il y a
eu avec voilà résultat sur 102 40 qui
est sans ambiguïté jean leonetti lui
était chargé de trouver le système de
départage il est très très déçu et le
dit ce matin dans dans le jdd est ce que
vous comprenez sa déception en gros il
ya un peu bosser pour rien ou quoi elle
est la mission de jean enfin pas
uniquement du genre
c'est celle de de nous tous l'équipe
dirigeante c'était de faire en sorte que
tous nos candidats potentiels accepte un
processus de deux décisions ont la
décision qui vient d'être prise l'a fait
que j'ai cru comprendre que tous nos
candidats sera liée à cela est donc ça
permettra voilà que le 4 décembre 6
correspond d'ailleurs au calendrier
traditionnel pour la droite que notre
candidat soit soit désigné vous avez vu
la déclaration on gagne pas la une
présidentielle en se repliant sur soi
dit jean les mains mais bien évidemment
on la gagne en s'ouvrant en confortant
d'abord son camp c'est comme ça quand on
commence et puis et puis ensuite en
souvent mais je fais confiance à nos
candidats pour avoir la capacité de le
faire vous nous dites le 4 décembre est
ce que vous nous confirmer que cette
date elle est définitivement arrêtée on
est certain que ça ne pourrait pas aller
plus vite maintenant et puis qu'est ce
qui vous reste comme modalités à définir
est ce que par exemple y aura des débats
entre les candidats ou pas ça ça va
dépendre aussi des candidats eux-mêmes
de ski le de ce qu'ils souhaitent oui la
date du 4 décembre une date qui était
arrêté qui correspond calendrier
traditionnel une présidentielle vous
savez
jacques chirac annoncé sa candidature le
le 4 novembre 94 mais elle était
confirmée un congrès du rpr fin fin
novembre nicolas sarkozy de mémoire en
2006 c'était le 29 novembre françois
fillon c'est le 27 novembre là le 4
décembre
certains disent trop tard vous perdez du
temps où écouter sur les présidentielles
précédentes je crois que je pas le
sentiment qu'on ait perdu du temps on
était rigoureusement sur le même
calendrier donc c'est un calendrier qui
permet à nos candidats d'avoir faire une
campagne interne mais en même temps
d'occuper aussi l'espace public sur
leurs sur leurs propositions et puis et
puis de recueillir les parrainages
puisque moi je souhaitais que ce ne soit
pas un concours de notoriété mais
vraiment pour les candidats qui
souhaitent et qui s'engage à ce pouvoir
représenter notre famille politique
devant les français donc on a mis et la
barre à 250
signature ce qui correspond à un
département différent c'est ça oui c'est
la loi organique de 62 pour se présenter
à l'élection présidentielle il faut
recueillir 56 500 signatures d'élus est
donc là on a divisé par deux en dix ans
et 250 signatures et le congrès
justement le ce mode de scrutin le
congrès réservée aux adhérents à l'air
est ce que ça ne va pas mécaniquement
renforcer les candidats 100% et l'air
comme michel barnier au détriment de
valérie pécresse qui rappelons le a
quitté le parti en 2019 selon vous oui
mais je pense que les les
les militants aient l'air comme comme
l'électorat de droit de manière générale
ils ont envie de gagner on a envie de
gagner et c'est la démonstration nous
avons fait à toutes les élections
territoriales depuis deux ans si on a
gagné toutes les élections sans aucune
exception les municipales les
sénatoriales les législatives partielles
les départementales les régionales c'est
parce qu'on l'a fait dans l'unité donc
vous savez que les adhérents et l'air il
aime plutôt des candidats qui sont
restés au sein de leur famille et au
détriment de candidats qui sont quittés
bien sûr mais
les adhérents et l'air ils ont envie
qu'on gagne c'est en ile de france comme
dans les hauts de france on aurait pu
faire des choix différents et avoir une
candidature purement et l'air en région
ile-de-france ou purement heller dans
les outrances ce qui nous importe c'est
de gagner et nous avons fait une très
bonne campagne en ile-de-france et dans
les hauts de france et grâce notamment
aux militants et aux adhérents ehlers a
permis à valérie pécresse des
présidentes d'être élu président de la
région ile-de-france et à xavier
bertrand d'être élu président des hauts
de france
alors tout le monde dit non mais nous
savons que les négociations entre
candidats ont commencé donc confirmé
j'imagine écouter sur l'hybride liberté
dieu merci de se parler autant qu'il le
souhaite un concept - oui
entendu que les salons touristiques
heureusement ray et christian jacob qui
se mettent d'accord en gros qu'on arrive
au congrès avec un nom vous arrivez au
congrès avec un an et qu'il n'y ait plus
qu'elle valide et goûter scud nous ce
que l'on a prévu c'est une procédure qui
se termine le 4 décembre non mais en
tant que non mais vous vous estimez que
ce serait le meilleur moyen d'avoir un
candidat mais bel et bien sûr mais ça
relève des candidats eux mêmes on a
prévu une procédure qui à son terme le 4
décembre et ça ne sera pas une procédure
fermer tous les candidats qui ont les
250 parrainage et qui souhaitent se
présenter devant les les militants les
adhérents le feront à cette occasion
après s'ils se mettent d'accord entre
eux c'est très bien mais mais moi je
considère que ça ça n'est plus de ma
responsabilité c'est de la leur vous
semblait il y avait une hypothèse qui au
départ
relever du bruit de couloir qui était
que xavier bertrand peut-être
participerait l'a finalement petit à
petit on s'aperçoit que d'aller bertrand
pourrait vraiment participer à un
congrès réservée aux adhérents à l'air
comment est ce que vous l'avez eue
xavier bertrand depuis hier au téléphone
à ce que vous avez 10 15 juillet gelé
hier soir comme je les ai quatre les
quatre candidats pour leur annoncer les
résultats
on sait qu'il pourrait participer aux
actions d'ailleurs annoncé par plusieurs
de personnes qui sont proches de lui et
son entourage ses porte parole et c'est
donc à tout et il n'exclut plus
l'hypothèse de revenir dans le jeu et de
se soumettre au vote des adhérents a non
seulement aller je fume et je pense
qu'il est plutôt clairement dans cette
logique mais maintenant à lui comme aux
autres de le confirmer ce qui devra son
quarter sheller nous on
liberté ii
si on a fait campagne pour lui dans les
hauts de france on lui a pas demandé de
ne pas exiger de lui qu'il prenne une
carte on a fait la même chose avec
valérie pécresse d'ailleurs valérie
pécresse a annoncé dès hier soir que le
entrer dans l'eau dans le processus du
congrès je pense que vous aviez bertrand
je veux savoir ses proches qu'il le
ferait incessamment donc voilà je
reviens sur une phrase que vous avez
prononcé quelques instants vous avez dit
n'importe quel candidat qui recueillera
les 250 signatures pourra se présenter
ça n'est pas fermée alors c'est ouvert
jusqu'au christian jacob je vais
observer vous savez on vous l'avez
entendu la rumeur qui est propagée par
certains des proches d'eric zemmour
qu'il pourrait lui-même se présenter
est-ce que c'est ouvert jusque là par
exemple tu nuis non on est dans les gens
qui se reconnaissent dans les valeurs de
la droite et du chanté sur le projet que
nous avons travaillé nous avons
travaillé depuis deux ans un vrai projet
d'alternance pour
se présenter face au français il faut
être capable d'incarner cette alternance
et ça ça passe par des propositions
précises donc on a fait un travail de 2
2 qui a duré deux ans avec des
représentants de la société civile
beaucoup de représentants du monde de
l'entreprise mais aussi de des experts
de tout de toute nature et chacune des
propositions a été soumise au vote est
validée est votée par nos militants et
envoie aujourd'hui bon ça nous que ça
crée un socle idéologique dans lequel
tous les candidats que l'on vient de
citer ceux se retrouve eric zemmour
nommé eric zemmour est dans une autre
logique moi j'ai toujours été très
clairs là dessus je les avais été clair
sur le les idées mais là je parle des
faits je parle je parle de voter je
parle du duellas dhr de serre mais le
cadre c'est se reconnaître dans les
valeurs de la droite et du centre
connaître mais oui c'est chris simms a
ainsi coûté je pense d'abord je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit qu'il soit candidat mais
ça c'est de sa responsabilité en tout
cas voilà il n'est pas dans notre
famille politique on sait tous
l'ensemble des dirigeants
de l'air se sont exprimé là-dessus il
n'y a pas dans mes couilles il n'est pas
de notre famille politique mais mais ça
n'est pas moi j'ai toujours dit d'abord
humainement c'est quelqu'un avec qui je
m'entends plutôt bien
g je considère qu'en tant polémiste il
est utile au débat public après sur la
ligne qui est la sienne bon ça n'est pas
la nôtre je veux dire on ne peut pas
tout ramener à la théorie du grand
remplacement mais on peut pas être dans
une logique des déclinistes vous
annoncer la guerre civile mais mais
ensuite ce matin j'ai entendu il dit que
vous êtes un parti de notables jeu le
site et que vous avez trahi le général
de gaulle ou écouter un peu de modestie
et d'humilité ne nuit pas
vous avez dans votre processus de dennis
désignation inclus une clause qui est
très intéressante la clause dite fillon
c'est à dire que ça vous permet de
brancher lyon l ai dit quoi c'est dû
d'empêchement si vous lui trouvez donc
cette clause d' empêchement qui
permettra de débrancher le candidat si
nécessaire et vous dites c'est écrit
pour quelques raisons que ce soit ça
veut dire quoi pour être très précis ça
veut dire s'il ya une affaire judiciaire
si le candidat est malade ou s'il est
mauvais si je suis dans les sondages
veut dépenser quelques raisons que ce
soit est d'abord c'est une décision qui
devra être collective donc à relève du
bureau politique du conseil national
ensuite donc quelque chose qui ait
décidé sur un coin de table ça peut être
un problème de santé ça peut être
d'accord on l'a vu dans les différentes
dans les dernières présidentielles peut
y avoir des situations de d'empêchement
et donc quand on l'a
candidats
c'est un article comme vous en avez dans
les statuts qui prévoient le pire ou à
la bombe et on a près un million c'est
pas anodin non non bien sûr mais on
n'est pas du tout dans ce cadre là mais
il était utile dans nos statuts de le
prévoir on a tous voila c'est aussi
peut-être bien sûr mais bon alors on a
dépassé cela le l'article est prévu mais
bon mais vous vous excitez pour
poursuivre les six mais c'est la force
de dissuasion que mick on n'en est pas
là oui bien sûr mais vous écarter ce qui
pourrait s'apparenter à une cause de
mauvais sondages qu on se dise amandine
ses autres candidats en lice en dessous
du ccc le bureau politique le conseil
national avec tous les gens qui peut y
avoir et le sérieux et des ied et autres
normes n'est pas du tout dans ce cadre
là nicolas sarkozy choisir en temps
voulu en tout cas il a déjeuné à une
bonne réponse oui il a déjeuné avec
beaucoup est ce qu'il vous a donné vous
le connaissez bien est ce que vous a
donné l'assurance qu'il allait soutenir
le candidat est là nous devons jamais
posé cette cette question mais j'ai
toute confiance de nicolas sarkozy et
les d'abord il a créé le parti a l'air
après après l'ump on est passés les
républicains on le doit à nicolas
sarkozy ensuite il a toujours été fidèle
et un peu plus fidèle à sa famille
politique il est toujours d'ailleurs je
vous rassure à jour de cotisation il
veille il veille à l'être et puis il est
pour nous tous une référence parce que
il a été président de la république et
donc ça lui donne à la fois une autorité
et puis un regard aussi qui est peu plus
distanciée on veut souvent le voir comme
l'ancien président des républicains il
faut le voir comme ancien président de
la république c'est hillary car c'est
une figure tutélaire me regarde
évidemment et tout le monde sait bien
évidemment bien évidemment bien
évidemment ça montre qu'il pèse toujours
dans notre appareil politique vous
n'imaginez pas qu'il ne soutienne pas
office bien sûr que non ce qui en a chez
vous qui sont un peu agacé par sa
proximité avec emmanuel macron il est
ancien président de la république et moi
je trouve très républicain bien qu'il
puisse avoir lorsque le l'actuel
président de la république lui demande
son avis pas sûr que les coudes souvent
d'ailleurs mais bon temps en temps il
semble qu'elle lui demande bon qu'est
ses relations normales ces républicains
donnent donc tout ça ne me choque
absolument parce que
non vous savez aussi que nicolas sarkozy
dit parfois en privé selon certaines
sources que la compétition et d'un bas
niveau cette année par rapport à la
dernière primaire où il y avait fillon
sarkozy juppé alors c'est d'en bas
niveau je les ai jamais entendu dire ce
genre de phrase
une étonnante que ça c'est pas le
demain l'imaginent pas s'exprimer de
cette manière après on est dans un
contexte qui est différent que les fois
précédentes effectivement puisque on
sortait d'une période on était
majoritaire là il ya dix ans qu'on est
dans l'opposition donc on a
effectivement pas un ancien président de
la république et deux anciens premiers
ministres mais c'est normal il ya dix
ans qu'on est plus au pouvoir
jules est ce que vous avez regardé le
débat entre jean luc mélenchon eric
zemmour jeudi soir qui a fait près de
noms qui a tout vous dire je les sers en
débat avec
les militants de paris avec la
fédération de paris
écoute les quais quand est-ce que vous
expliquer l'engouement eux
pour ce débat par rapport à valérie
pécresse et qui a fait autour d'un
million de téléspectateurs je crois à
nice et un réel engouement pour le débat
entre deux personnes dont vous fin des
grosses différences avec les deux
personnalités comment vous expliquer
qu'il y ait eu un il ya un engouement
médiatique incontestable après
c'est moi qui commence à avoir vécu pas
mal de présidentielle il ya ce qui
relève de l'engouement médiatique et ce
qui relève de l'intention de vote ce
sont deux choses différentes viendra le
temps des propositions concrètes sur
tous les sujets de préoccupation des
français qui sont sur la serre sur la
sécurité sur la justice mais sur la
santé sur la lutte contre la sécheresse
et la radicalité oui parce que ça occupe
un espace médiatique avec deux
personnalités qui joue tout sur cet
espace médiatique ignorions on n'est pas
abreuvés de propositions sur leur
programme mais ils sont dans l'espace
médiatique et l'occupent voilà et puis
bah tout ce vous lui faites vous leur
faites cette publicité et l'engouement
n'est pas que médiatique christian jacob
et concerne aussi votre parti parce que
quand on regarde les sondages d'accord
ce ne sont que des sondages mais il ya
un quart des électeurs de françois
fillon de 2017 qui s'apprêteraient à
voter pour eric zemmour vous leur dites
quoi à ses électeurs qui sont encore les
vôtres aujourd'hui nous allons être
c'est à peu près la même chose que l'on
nous disait même qu'un jour avant les
régionales souvenez-vous l'occasion des
régionales à chaque fois que j'étais
invité sur un plateau de télévision on
n'avait qu'une question à me poser alors
vous allez vous rallier au front
national ou
la république en marche la réalité c'est
qu'on a gagné comme jamais les élections
mais là je n'en avais de fermer bien
boulangerie mais jusqu'à ce que dit à
ces gens pour les convaincre de rester
leur dire qu'ils vont être attentif au
projet qui va être le nôtre comme
c'était le cas aux régionales et au delà
des bulles médiatiques ils ont voté avec
sérieux et donc je suis très confiant
parce que oui le travail que nous avons
fait depuis deux ans c'est qu'on a
construit un socle idéologique souvenez
vous il ya encore un an 18 mois y
compris dans notre famille les uns
disaient voilà c'est la ligne
souverainiste qui doit l'emporter les
autres non c'est une ligne libérale non
il faut une approche sociale ce sujet
est résolu vous avez plus débat tout
simplement parce que le socle
idéologique dans le travail que nous
avons fait nous l'avons complètement
reconstruit avec notre projet et vous
voyez les interventions des uns et des
autres bien entendu de nos trois
candidats aient l'air mais aux deux
candidats pour le droit du centre pour
le droit du sol sur l'immigration s'est
pas tout à fait le même discours depuis
paris
christian jacob s'est par exemple eric
ciotti lui carrément et reconnaît des
points communs nombreux avec eric
zemmour il va même plus loin il dit
second tour et zemmour macron je vote
zemmour mme d'abord je n'imagine pas ce
type de second tour ensuite nous nous
sommes sur une ligne nous sommes
candidats à l'adhésion oui mais bien sûr
mais bien sûr mais tout le monde
s'exprime avec la liberté qu'il souhaite
moi ce que je sais c'est que nous avons
aujourd'hui un socle idéologique et
construit qui n'est plus en débat parce
qu'il a été voté par chacun chaque de
nos militants s'est exprimé sur chacune
des propositions et nous avons abordé
tous les sujets de préoccupations des
français donc ce débat il est clos pour
être très clair qu'est ce qui vous
différencie aujourd'hui vous
biologiquement d'un eric zemmour
pas écouté le fais je l'expliquais tout
à l'heure par exemple sur le sujet de la
laïcité la laïcité c'est la liberté de
croire ou ne pas croire ou de ne pas
croire ça ne peut pas être le rejet
d'une d'une religion de la même façon
qu'on ne peut pas tout ramener à cette
théorie du grand remplacement avec une
logique déclinistes on nous annonce
chaque matin la guerre civile la réalité
de la préoccupation de nos compatriotes
se sont certes les sujets sur
l'immigration et nous faisons des
propositions très claires dans ce
dot dans ce domaine la lutte contre le
terrorisme la justice mais c'est aussi
la santé c'est aussi le pouvoir d'achat
c'est aussi la liberté qu'il faut
redonner aux entreprises pour la
création et le développement de nos
entreprises l'allègement des charges et
des normes les sujets de dépendance pour
les personnes âgées c'est à cela
il est sûr sur un sujet mais mais c'est
aussi le talent qui est le sien celui
d'un polémiste et qui est aujourd'hui
qui est utile au débat public comme
polémiste un tout dernier mot à ce sujet
je propose d'écouter deux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
c'est que zemmour un raciste
oui je pense bien sûr vous attend la
suite vous avez été condamné pour ça
fait très longtemps qu'on l'entend tenir
des propos absolument
indécent vous êtes en danger pour notre
pays vous avez une vision rabougrie de
la france est-ce qu'il est raciste et
règlements non cotées mots je connais
avec zemmour je ne partage pas la ligne
encore une fois cette ligne déclinistes
où chaque jour c'est la guerre civile va
arriver un peu d'optimisme
non y lisait moore léger moore
ce qui il ya au moins un point que l'on
partage c'est que
on considère que marine le pen est
totalement décrédibilisée pour être en
situation de pouvoir gagner l'élection
présidentielle et je partage pas ce que
nous avons vu voyez vous il ne sera pas
au deuxième temps ce que l'on a vu aux
élections régionales est riche
d'enseignements il ya six ans aux
élections régionales le front national
était en tête au premier tour dans six
régions de france cette fois ci ils ne
l'ont été que dans une seule région de
france on voit bien qu'à une perte de
crédibilité très forte bien sûr elle
conserve un socle électoral solide mais
la crédibilité la capacité à pouvoir
être président de la république
je pense que y compris une partie de son
électorat c'est complètement détourné ça
c'est l'analyse de zemmour je pense que
de ce point de vue il n'a pas tort
monsieur jacob le caporal-chef maxime
blasco est mort au combat c'était
avant-hier au mali 52e soldat mort au
mali depuis début de l'opération barkan
la france est en train de se retirer du
mali d'ailleurs le président du manidem
en soi un abandon est ce que le
calendrier vous jugé adéquat puisque il
faut accélérer notre en retrait non moi
je pense qu'il ne faut pas le
l'accélérer là ce que l'on voit bien la
difficulté d'abord on je soulignais
l'hommage à ce héros dans sa famille
pensée pour sa famille et ses frères
d'armes ne nous nos soldats qui est
risquent leur vie chaque jour sur ce
terrain d'opération pour notre sécurité
à tous parce qu'ils luttent contre le
contre le terrorisme et
et vraiment leur doit une une
reconnaissance infinie ensuite sur leur
très bon la décision du président de la
république c'est de passer sur
l'opération takouba qui est une
opération européenne
en s'appuyant également sur les les
forces armées est légal bon ce que l'on
voit bien aujourd'hui c'est que tant
l'opération takouba qui a du mal à
prendre son envol que les les forces
armées locales bon je les vois pas en
capacité de se substituer aujourd'hui à
notre opération non qu'on passerait de
cinq mille hommes à 2500 alors j'ai bien
noté qu'on serait sans doute sur des
opérations plus ciblées
avec aussi les groupes terroristes qui
se sont déplacés concentrer sur des
secteurs géographiques ultime et met
tout ça aujourd'hui mais me semble m'ont
compliqué à réaliser donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut s je pense qu'il faut du
temps
il faut le faire aussi avec les
informations je n'ai pas n'est pas accès
que seul le ministère de la défense on
peut avoir accès mais
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'ailleurs de renforcer l'autonomie
européenne
et on a besoin parallèlement à l'otan
d'avoir une propre autonomie européenne
le lag l'action de l'otan aujourd'hui
est très ciblée
à l'égard de la protection de la faune
vers la chine et la russie or nous on a
d'autres terrains d'action qui préoccupe
l'union européenne l'est notamment et
notamment l'afrique donc on a un intérêt
a effectivement pouvoir être plus plus
autonomes et favorable à une défense
européenne alors s'il s'agit de parler
d'une armée européenne absolument pas
dire on n'est pas si long que je sais on
est en incapacité de le faire décision
des vingt-sept à l'unanimité aura jamais
la seule armée l'union européenne qui a
une capacité de projection en 24 heures
c'est la france donc il faut sortir de
cette chimère en revanche on a travaillé
sur un fond de défense européen et je
trouve que c'était une proposition de la
commission c'est une c'est une bonne
idée bon elle devait tête de ce fonds
devait être doté je crois 13 milliards
d'euros on n'est plus qu'à 8 milliards
d'euros parce que certain nombre de pays
à commencer d'ailleurs par le
gouvernement français se sont réjouies
un peu trop vite de l'élection de joe
biden en disant ça y est trump est parti
tout va pour dans le meilleur des mondes
avec joe biden tout a changé la réalité
c'est qu'on reste sur une logique et
america first et donc les américains se
préoccupent de leurs intérêts
et leurs intérêts sont pas toujours les
nôtres justement cette crise
diplomatique
est-ce que là la france quand cette
histoire des sous marins est ce que la
voix de la france est sortie affaiblie
oui oui peux pas vous dire que non
malheureusement la voix de la france est
sortie affaiblie moins
n'a pas bien entendu tous les éléments
d'information mais entre cet accord ce
contrat annoncé avec tambours et
trompettes en 2016 le contrat du siècle
il montrait d'ailleurs vous voyez même
si l'arrêt sur le temps long et 56
minutes bien sûr bien sûr sauf que j'ai
du mal à imaginer que le 15 septembre
quand la décision de l'alliance entre
l'australie les états unis et le royaume
uni tombe que tout ça tombe en 24 heures
et qui avait pas de signes avant
coureurs r je suis un peu surpris que
voilà tout le monde joue la surprise
vous voulez aussi une commission
denquête je pense qu'il faut que la
transparence complète soit ce soit faite
sur ce sur ce sujet bon j'avoue ne pas
comprendre comment on est comment on en
est arrivé là
mais c'est aussi sur les jeunes pendant
une porte nord éclair question jacob oui
ou non pour la commission denquête oui
oui moi il ya une commission denquête je
suis tout à fait favorable bien entendu
nous l'avons souhaité au nom d'un groupe
qui je pense même que le président de
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
devrait prendre l'initiative en tant que
président de l'assemblée nationale et le
faire au nom de l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires
plutôt que la commission denquête soit
demandée par tel ou tel groupe compte
tenu de l'importance du sujet il me
semble que le président de l'assemblée
nationale serait fondé à le faire en son
nom et au nom de l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires nicolas sarkozy pourtant
et plus compréhensif que vous avec le
chef de l'état puisque il dit qu'il a eu
raison d'être fermé que le comportement
des états unis est inadmissible pour
vous partager cette vision est stocké
manuel macro à gérer le mieux possible
aux noix je tiens je ne sais pas parce
que je vous dis moi je n'ai pas tous les
éléments du dossier ce que je sais c'est
que j'ai du mal à comprendre que cette
décision de l'australie des etats-unis
et du royaume-uni tombe le 15 septembre
et que personne n'ait rien vu avant et
que c'est la surprise générale c'est ça
qui me stimule les mâles tour par
exemple comment on en est on en est
arrivé là il faut des renseignements je
ne sais pas c'est pour ça qu'il faut que
la lumière soit faite c'est pour ça que
j'aurais que souhaitait aussi que le
président de la république s'exprime sur
un sujet de cette importance il aurait
été important que l'on en entende que
l'on sache effectivement comment on en
est arrivé là et pour quel et pour
quelles raisons et et donc je reviens à
cela c'est un signe qui montre bien
encore une fois que les préoccupations
des américains ne sont pas les toujours
les nôtres sont parfois les nôtres sont
nos alliés mais notamment sur le sur le
pacifique leur seule préoccupation c'est
de s'opposer à la chine et moi j'aurais
aimé aussi puisqu'on est sur cette zone
du pacifique qui on entende aussi
beaucoup plus là la voix de la france
est là pour le coup je fais le reproche
directement emmanuel macron et à ses
deux gouvernements successifs parce que
aussi bien edouard philippe que jean
castex totalement silencieux sur ce qui
se passe en nouvelle calédonie
ce troisième ce troisième référendum on
n'entend pas de position française est
de voir les premiers ministres qui joue
les préfets ou les hauts commissaires en
disant on va s'assurer que l'élection se
pinçant tout en toute transparence mais
on parle de la place de la france et
même de l'union européenne sur le
pacifique justement et on n'entend pas
la voix du président de la république et
on n'entend pas la voix de ses deux
premiers ministres successifs
revenant sur la crise et sous marin il
ya eu des échanges très très tendue
entre le secrétaire d'état américain
anthony blinken et le ministre afghan gr
jean yves le drian emmanuel macron et
joe biden se sont parlés est ce que vous
estimez aujourd'hui que la france a été
trop est ce qu on a été trop gentils
vis-à-vis des etats-unis où est son
ambassadeur au parent à washington des
métros par washington est ce que vous
vous exprimez que moi je pour répondre à
cette question je veux que la
transparence soit faite que comprenez
que c'est compliqué pour moi de répondre
là dessus dans la mesure où dans les
responsabilités qui sont les miennes et
ce qui est tout à fait normal je n'ai
pas accès
à des dossiers qui sont classés secret
défense ou à des entretiens directs
entre deux présidents de la république
ou deux ministres de la défense donc je
demande à ce que la lumière soit faite
et comment on a pu en arriver là le coup
de colère du président de la république
du ministre des affaires étrangères
viennent entendu que je le comprends et
je le partage mais
encore une fois voilà comment tout ça
tombe d'un seul coup le 15 septembre et
que personne quarante huit heures avant
ne voit rien venir alors qu'on était sur
un contrat signé depuis 2016 j'imagine
quand même qu'ils aient eu des signes
avant-coureurs faudrait vous interroger
sur une autre colère celle des habitants
du nord de paris et d'une partie de la
seine saint denis les consommateurs de
crack du jardin d'eole qui est désormais
manifestement est malheureusement très
connus nos concitoyens ont été déplacées
de kilomètres on les a mis dans un car
pour les amener à la lisière de la seine
saint denis on a construit ce mur l'on
voit derrière moi pour les empêcher de
traverser et de gagner pourtant
d'ailleurs valérie pécresse candidate au
congrès sioniste a maintenant étaient
sur place et bien ce matin je pense je
prenne ses habitudes
elle est indigne et tout le monde est en
ligne et vous l'êtes aussi oui et on
fait quoi concrètement alors oui ce que
l'on fait concrètement c'est le
contraire de ce qui a été fait depuis
depuis des années c'est à dire que on
voit bien qu'on a une une politique de
prévention dans ce domaine qui a échoué
et on a besoin de renforcer d'ailleurs
ça fait partie du projet les dés des
républicains sur le le renforcement de
la prévention et les soins à apporter à
ces personnes et ces pas en les parquant
d'un endroit à l'autre qu'on va qu'on va
résoudre les choses c'est tout ce qui
n'a pas été fait avant hier
aujourd'hui on voit bien que cette
décision n'a pas de sens puis l'idée du
mur elle est allée choquant
juste un mot concrètement du coup ça
veut dire quoi d'aidé centre de sevrage
vous êtes favorable ou pas les salles de
soude comme on dit que la non sur les
salles de shoot
jégo comment le gouvernement a dit oui
anne hidalgo
mais je mets simplement on doit les
faire dans un encadrement médical avec
une politique de prévention et ça n'est
pas aujourd'hui ce qui se passe dans les
salles de shoot regarder il se passe
bien souvent on a du trafic aux entrées
on a des difficultés dans tout le
quartier où s'installent donc on voit
bien que cette politique de prévention
qui est à la fois de
salle mais concrètement c'est de ne rien
avoir fait depuis cinq ans on l'aimé oui
aujourd'hui c'est de faire un
accompagnement médicalisé qui n'est pas
fait en ce moment on est dans un système
de partage est aujourd'hui la
responsabilité et les sur les chèques
qui était celle la politique de santé
depuis depuis une dizaine d'années alors
lequel ce sont les envoient à l'hôpital
je pense que ça relève davantage d'un
encadrement médical de mon point de vue
et d'accompagnement de santé qui n'est
pas fait aujourd'hui
que vous dites ça remonte à dix ans
peut-être même avant et oui mais bien
entendu bien entendu mais le
développement des stupéfiants ça date
pas de l'arrivée de tel ou tel président
de la république benson va vous dire ça
simplement la politique de prévention a
été abandonné par ce gouvernement
je voudrais vous interroger au sujet de
la situation en guyane alors non point
de vue sanitaire aller catastrophique
c'est un drame qui est en train de se
passer sur le fond du coc vide les taux
de sedan d'incidents sont exploser les
taux d'hospitalisation site l'incidence
on est à plus de cinq cent pour cent
mille alors qu'en france on est à 60
redescendu à 60
christiane taubira refuse d'appeler les
guyanais officiellement à se faire
vacciner elle n'est pas anti vaccins
elle même qu'elle a été vaccinée elle
refuse de porter cette ce message tout
comme le président de la collectivité
territoriale de de guyane comment vous
réagissez c'est presque ça me choque
comme choc au plus haut point lorsqu'on
est responsable politique
giron s'engage aujourd'hui on voit bien
si on a réussi
sur sur l'hexagone à endiguer la
progression de ce virus et bien grâce à
la vaccination
arrêtez de dire n'importe quoi comme l'a
dit madame taubira et puis qui parle de
la guyane et qui parle de la france
comme si elle mettait là la guyane en
dehors de la république c'est beau me
choque à chaque fois et elles devraient
avoir l'honnêteté de dire que
aujourd'hui ici encore une fois sur
l'hexagone on a réussi à endiguer le
virus s'est effectivement les gestes
barrière c'est tout ce qu'il a pu
accompagner mais c'est d'abord la
politique de vaccination
il faut s'engager très clairement dans
une politique de vaccination dynamique
en guyane comme dans l'ensemble des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
et la politique de vaccination et puis
il ya le pass sanitaire bientôt en
conseil des ministres le projet de loi
va arriver pour qu'il soit prolongé
après le 15 novembre vous êtes favorable
vous allez voter pour moi je pense que
sur le sur le pince sanitaires
il faut l'adapter au cas par cas c'est à
dire que quand effectivement il n'y a
plus de risque sanitaire mais ça encore
une fois ça relève des experts de santé
nous le dira lorsqu'il n'y a plus de
risque de pouvoir alléger les
contraintes tout le monde y est
favorable en revanche si le risque
demeure il faut le maintenir
aujourd'hui on le fait tous les uns les
autres on va au restaurant on sort notre
téléphone vous espérez que c'est dans
les habituels maintenant trois secondes
à le faire donc si on peut alors il ya
toujours d'autres contraintes ya la
contrainte du masque dans les dents dans
les transports dont bon kéké parfois
difficile à supporter mais donc il faut
savoir s'adapter à l'évolution du virus
et le faire intelligemment il faut qu'on
sorte de cette situation j'ai justement
le passé ni terre a accéléré la
vaccination en france aujourd'hui on a
un des pays les plus vaccinée d'europe
avec le taux de vaccination plus élevé
parce que finalement vous saluer la
gestion de la crise sanitaire de ce
gouvernement de maintenir un accroc sur
ses décisions brutales on accompagne et
pour lesquelles on a voté
en revanche sur la gestion de la crise
combien d'erreurs avant quand combien
d'erreurs sur les masques sur les tests
sur la politique de vaccination rappelez
vous au départ la catastrophe que
c'était heureusement que les
collectivités territoriales ont été là
pour se substituer aux failles de l'état
qui était catastrophique l'état était
incapable d'organiser quoi que ce soit
on voyait les mini se contredire en
permanence sur les plateaux heureusement
qu'on a eu des maires qu'on ait des
présidents de départements qu'on ait des
présidents de région qui ont pris le
sujet à bras le corps donc le
gouvernement ne mérite aucun crédit à
vos yeux ne le dit pas mais j'en suis
tiré les enseignements vous savez quand
laurent wauquiez par exemple s'engage
sur les deux les tests à grande échelle
et de voir le ministre de la santé qui
se moque de lui publiquement et après on
se dit bas effectivement laurent
wauquiez a montré la bonne voie et de la
même façon que dans les régions lorsque
nos présidents de région
ont été distribués les masques c'était
nous le cas en ile de france mais dans
beaucoup d'autres régions heureusement
les présidents de région était là et
heureusement dans les villes on était
capable de mettre à disposition les
salles l'état avait été incapable
d'envisager sa six mois dans ma ville de
provins le maire de provins n'avait pas
mis à disposition une salle à
disposition du personnel pour le faire
ça devait être fait en est d'identifier
les personnes qui avaient plus de 70 ans
puisque dans l'hôpital public on ne
savait pas les identifier la rs n'avait
pas pensé à ça que ça veut dire que le
seae bravo aux collectivités
territoriales et ça veut dire qu'ils
songent à rio que la candidate ou le
candidat ait l'air sera un girondin que
vous allez faire des propositions pour
plus de décentralisation pour plus de
pouvoir dans les régions pour plus de
pouvoir où l'on met dans notre projet je
vous invite à lire dans le détail notre
projet vous verrez les parrainer pour
l'instant six et dix des n'ai pas choisi
tu la mets mon nom mais pas que des
amendements bien entendu que chaque
candidat sa manière de l'incarner etc
mais la ligne qui est très claire dans
le projet c'est de s'appuyer davantage
sur les collectivités territoriales et
aussi de ne sortir ses tutelles jamais
on n'a eu un état aussi centralisateur
53 la tradition la doite rabin oui mais
la seule préoccupation des manuels
macron c'est de mettre sous tutelle les
collectivités territoriales c'est ce qui
fait en se fichant du monde avec la taxe
d'habitation
c'est à dire ce système on s amuse en
france est con con qu'on leur retire un
impôt en réalité on met les
collectivités sous tutelle parce qu'ils
payent toujours le même niveau d'impôts
ce qui ne payent pas à l'échelle de la
commune ils payent à l'échelle nationale
donc ça ne change rien pour le
contribuable simplement on oblige les
collectivités
allez demander gentiment à l'état de
bien vouloir lui compenser alors que moi
je souhaite que les qui paye décide et
quand les collectivités ont une
responsabilité ont une compétence et
bien qu'ils aient les moyens de
financement qui l'accompagné de moyens
de financement dynamique ça doit aller
jusqu'où pardon dernier mot mais ça doit
aller jusqu'où est ce qu'il faut en gros
comme certains le demandent qui est des
transferts de compétences jusqu'à la
limite du régalien qu'on vous le
régalien reste pour eux pour le
gouvernement que tout le reste aux
collectivités pas tout le reste il faut
définir le cadre dans lequel ça peut ça
peut se faire il ya certaines de
compétences de proximité voyez par
exemple sur les aérer moi je souhaite
que les présidents de région président
les airs est son côté des directeurs des
ars mais qui a un regard politique qui
soit posée dessus et erreurs encore qui
a été fait par le gouvernement en
matière de santé souvenez-vous des
tensions entre le public et le privé
qu'on associés pas le privé parce qu'on
était sur une vision hospital au centré
sur sur le sujet et que les rs
fonctionner avec les hôpitaux alors
qu'on avait des cliniques à côté qui
avaient la possibilité d'avoir des
salles de réanimation a ses failles de
quoi oui c'est ça c'est fait avec le
temps et ça c'est fait pourquoi parce
que dans les hôpitaux ils sont présidées
par des mères les conseils de
surveillance sur présidée par des mères
quand un moment on dit arrêtons d'être
stupide regardons l'ensemble du plateau
de choix qu'il ya sur un territoire et
qui peut intervenir mais sans les élus
ça ne se serait pas fait parce qu'on
avait un état complètement bureaucratisé
avec un président de la république qui
n'a aucune expérience de cela qu'ils
découvrent au fur et à mesure ne sais
pas comment fonctionne que lorsque nos
territoires issus de la crise sanitaire
oui parce qu'on parle beaucoup
d'économies quand même en ce moment est
ce que vous diriez comme valérie
pécresse qui emmanuel macron est en
train de cramer la caisse c'est à dire
qu'ils dépensent de façon inconsidérée
en fin de mandat la gestion des finances
publiques est totalement calamiteuse
d'ailleurs c'était souligné par la cour
des comptes lorsque la cour des comptes
dit que le budget est incomplet traduit
en langage courant ça veut dire qu'il
est insincère c'est à dire que
concrètement monsieur macron fait des
annonces dans tous les sens qui ne sont
absolument pas budgétée
aujourd'hui quand il annonce le rsa
jeunes à peu près deux milliards d'euros
par parents lorsqu'ils annoncent un
milliard cinq à marseille tout ça ne
figure dans aucun budget donc on est
vraiment dans de l'insincérité
budgétaire sur la gestion des dépenses
publiques c'est une catastrophe la
gestion des dépenses publiques par
emmanuel macron et ses différents
gouvernements si vous prend des exemples
précis or crise en dehors
dudu du plan de relance et
d'accompagnement sanitaires les dépenses
publiques sous edouard philippe emmanuel
macron augmente de 2,6 pour cent par an
les chiffres de 2010 neuf sous françois
hollande ait été à 1,4 pour cent et pour
moi c'est vraiment pas une référence
vous parlez de françois hollande sur la
gestion des dépenses publiques sous
nicolas sarkozy il était à peu près 1%
entre 0,8 et 1,3 c'est à dire que depuis
que monsieur macro est là et avec
edouard philippe qui en assumer les
premiers responsabilités dire que là
pour le coup on a laissé exploser la
dépense publique on joue tout sur la
dette en on est en sortie de crise et il
faut cesser de relancer en héros hors
plan de relance les chiffres que je vous
donne 100 milliards d'augmentation la
dépense publique sur les trois ans qui
viennent de se passer les trois heures
c'est à dire de 19,2 à fin 2020 2021 et
2022 on a 100 milliards d'augmentation
de la de la dépense publique
justin et dernier mot emmanuel macron
fait le pari de la dette ils ne pensent
qu'à endetté la france quand tous les
autres pays de l'union européenne se
désendette or aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'on a un retour de l'inflation si vous
avez de l'inflation mécaniquement vous
allez avoir une augmentation des taux
ailleurs la banque centrale de norvège
s'y est pas trompé et vient d'augmenter
ses taux est vraisemblablement que
d'autres banques vont suivre de ramener
un instant sur le plan de relance parce
que si votre candidate ou candidat est
élu il les rites rade cette situation il
y a notamment des milliers des milliers
d'entreprises qui ont été aidés par les
dac l'état qui ont contracté ce fameux
pge d'ailleurs dans votre livre laquelle
j'en ai tellement vu vous expliquer qu'à
plusieurs reprises vouliez un ministre
un ministère des entreprises
imaginons que les républicains et vos
pouvoirs que dites vous à ces
entreprises qui ont contracté cpg ont
les etam on les efface on les accompagne
comment fait-on pour les étals bien
évidemment on est fâche pas on n'efface
pas en état c'est un sujet qu'on sait
très bien sûr bien sûr mais on est allé
et
et en accompagne on accompagne les
entreprises mais mais mais ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui
ce qui est scandaleux sur les dépenses
publiques cdu du quoi qu'il en coûte on
passe à peu importe ce que ça coûte tout
pour ma réélection c'est ça la seule
préoccupation en cas d'échec mais non
non non non non non jamais attendez
jamais jamais la cour des comptes
d'affaires un tel rappel sur le budget
ce qui vient est ce que vient de dire la
cour des comptes en disant que le budget
était incomplet encore une fois en
langage courant ça veut dire un sincère
ça veut dire que le président de la
république annonce des dépenses qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas ne sont pas
financés très clairement non choix il
ment éhontément en annonçant des
dépenses en sachant pertinemment qu'il
sera incapable de tenir aucun engagement
choix le budget insincère et donc ça ça
doit être clarifiée moi c'est ça j'aime
le jugement qui est donnée par la cour
des comptes est un jugement d'une
extrême sévérité il en reste 30 secondes
alors vous parle beaucoup de choses dans
ce livre j'en ai tellement vu de mieux
celle de lire les présidents des
républiques stable je revois les laisser
nos téléspectateurs à ce niveau s'il a
envie de le lire évidemment mais je
crois pas je les lis pourtant j'ai pas
vu anguila merkel dans le livre il ya
une page qui se tourne en allemagne la
chancelière va quitter le pouvoir après
16 ans vous êtes inquiet vous êtes
confiant sur la nature de notre lien
avec l'allemagne et ce qui va se passer
à partir de demain
l'histoire de l'union européenne c'est
une histoire qui est lié au tandem au
tandem franco-allemand de tout temps
tous nos présidents l'ont fait
et je pense que ça continuera bien
entendu c'est une étape qui tourne et
notamment pour les pour les allemands
mais même pour nous parce que angela
merkel était connue de de tous les
français et elle a travaillé avec tous
les présidents quelques quel qu'il soit
donc moi je fais confiance à nos amis de
la cd où il a ses sous pour remporter
cette élection ils le feront
vraisemblablement dans un cadre de
collis coalition ça n'est pas notre
tradition c'est pour ça qu'on va pas
savoir ce soir qui sera le prochain
chancelier mais en tout cas on a du
monde
alliée de la cdu où il ya beaucoup
christian jacob j'en ai tellement vu
c'est chez robert laffont jours montre
ce livre merci d'avoir été l'invité de
bfm politique aujourd'hui